bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat l'école parvient elle encore à
transmettre les valeurs de la république
la question n'est bien sûr pas nouvelle
mais elle se pose avec une résonance
toute particulière au lendemain des
attentats meurtriers de début janvier
alors on se souvient dès la fin janvier
le gouvernement a annoncé 11 mesures de
mobilisation de l'école pour les valeurs
de la république et au même moment au
sénat sur proposition du groupe ump
une commission denquête a été créé sur
le fonctionnement du service public de
l'éducation sur la perte de repères
républicains et les difficultés
rencontrées par le corps enseignant je
propose aujourd'hui de revoir une
audition d'alain finkielkraut mené par
cette commission
le philosophe essayiste et membre de
l'académie française dresse un constat
très pessimiste pour lui la république
semble renoncer au moment même où elle
est défié et si l'on ne fait rien et
bien elle court à la catastrophe
je propose de découvrir tout de suite
ces diagnostics et ses propositions en
salle médicis
nous débutons ce matin notre séance
d'auditions en recevant monsieur alain
finkielkraut
écrivain essayiste philosophe et membre
de l'académie française comme le bureau
de la commission denquête l'a décidé
cette audition sera capté et diffusé en
direct sur le site internet du sénat
avec la corde croûte et elle sera
également accessible en version papier
sur le site internet du sénat dans le
recueil des travaux de commission
agrégée de lettres modernes enseignant
en lycée technologique puis à l'école
polytechnique
vous avez fait preuve tout au long de
votre carrière d'un grand intérêt pour
les questions d'éducation
vous avez notamment publié enseigné les
lettres aujourd'hui en 2003 puis en 2007
la querelle de l'école un livre issu des
débats que vous avez menées à l'en tête
de france culture
vous vous présentez vous même comme un
fervent défenseur de l'école
républicaine
je rappelle que vous avez été entendu
comme expert auprès de la commission
chargée de rédiger un livre est destiné
à faire vivre l'idée républicaine dans
les écoles créé en 2003 par luc ferry
alors ministre de l'éducation nationale
vous avez aussi été nommés membres avant
d'en démissionner par suite de
désaccords avec son rapport de la
commission nationale du débat sur
l'avenir de l'école et à la lumière de
votre expérience dans l'enseignement et
de votre réflexion sur l'école vous
pourrez sans doute nous éclairer sur les
difficultés qui existent en matière de
transmission des valeurs de la
république
avant de vous passer la parole le
formalisme des commission denquête me
conduit à vous demander de prêter
serment
je suis également tenus de vous indiquer
que tout faux témoignage devant deux
commissions seraient passibles des
peines prévues aux articles 434 13 à 434
15 du code pénal c'est un formalisme
auquel je ne peux me soustraire
en conséquence je vous invite à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité vous levé la main droite et
dit je le jure je jure je vous remercie
selon l' usage habituel je vous propose
de faire part de vos observations durant
une dizaine de minutes après quoi notre
rapporteur jacques perrin et les membres
de la commission denquête ici présents
qui le souhaitent pourront vous proposez
et vous poser des questions je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup je serai j'essaierai donc
d'être aussi sincère que possible et je
partirai
de la très fameuse conférence de renan
prononcer je crois en 1882 qu'est ce
qu'une nation renom dit que la
communauté d intérêts est assurément un
lien puissant entre les hommes les
intérêts cependant suffisent d'elle à
faire une nation je ne le crois pas la
communauté les intérêts fait les traités
de commerce et ensuite renan donne ça
très fameuse définition une nation est
une âme un principe spirituel deux
choses à vrai dire qu'ils n'en font
qu'une constituent cette âme ce principe
spirituel lui ni dans le passé l'autre
dans le présent l'une est la possession
en commun d'un riche legs de souvenirs
l'autre est le consentement actuel le
désir de vivre ensemble la volonté de
continuer à faire valoir l'héritage
indivise l'homme messieurs ne
s'improvise pas
la république a confié à l'école la
tâche de transmettre l'héritage et de le
transmettre autant qu'il est possible à
tous ses enfants
la tâche aujourd'hui se complique
elle est de plus en plus malaisée le
contexte de l'école est défavorable à
l'école simone veil la philosophe disait
que la formation de la faculté
d'attention et le but véritable est
presque l'unique intérêt des études
or la tension est aujourd'hui mis à mal
par la connexion plus les élèves
sont connectés et moins ils sont
attentifs
tous les professeurs en font l'amère
expérience et je nous y viendrons
peut-être mais là c'est une parenthèse
il ne me semble pas que la numérisation
accéléré de l'école résoudra le problème
elle risque au contraire de l'aggraver
d'autre part l'internet mettant tout le
savoir à disposition semble rendent
inutiles
l'acquisition du savoir une confusion
s'instaure entre mise à disposition et
acquisitions deuxième difficulté liée
celle-là non aux nouvelles technologies
et au nouvel individu que ces
technologies façonne mais au nouveau
public scolaire avec l'immigration de
peuplement d'autres héritages d'autres
généalogie entre massivement à l'école
que faire
l'école hésite
d'autant plus qu'à la différence de
renan elle a partiellement honte de son
héritage
le vingtième siècle nous séparent de la
conférence de 882 et c'est une sorte de
trou béant le 26
siècle c'est le siècle des nationalisme
débridé du totalitarisme et de la
violence coloniale
dès lors un mot est devenu tabou c'est
le terme d'assimilation je suis moi-même
contemporain d'une époque où la
simulation régner je ne dirais pas sévi
sais je viens d'une famille fraîchement
naturalisés nous avons même bénéficié
d'une interrelations d'une
naturalisation collective alors que
j'avais un an et j'ai connu donc
l'assimilation mais ils ne mettaient pin
n'a jamais été demandé de me fondre dans
la masse de sacrifier mon identité juive
pour être un meilleur français
il m'a été possible d'assimiler une part
de la culture française
donc ce n'était pas selon moi une
violence
c'était un don qu'en est il aujourd'hui
j'ai apporté un rapport qui n'a certes
pas été suivi des faits mais qui traduit
un état d'esprit répandue dans
l'éducation nationale
c'est un rapport remis au premier
ministre sur la refondation des
politiques d'intégration rédigé par un
conseiller d'état thierry tuot une
grande nation pour une société inclusive
et je lis ceci alors c'est intéressant
d'ailleurs parce que ce rapport par déjà
du principe que l'assimilation
perpétuation quelque sorte de la
violence coloniale doit être doit être
évidemment écartées mais il s'en prend à
au concept qui avait déjà remplacé la
simulation celui d'intégration puisqu'il
est écrit l'intégration mène des
populations mal définis sur un parcours
incertain pour rejoindre on ne sait quoi
et il s'en prend aussi au passé révolu
d'une france chevrotante confite dans
des traditions imaginaire ce passé
révolu dont l'école a précisément la
charge donc tout se passe comme si avec
l'assimilation et même l'intégration la
colonisation continuer et c'est aussi je
crois ce qui ressort de ce qu'on a
faussement appelée l'esprit du 11
janvier
après donc les grandes manifestations
qui a suivi les tueries de charlie hebdo
et du magasin hyper cacher de vincennes
parce que à peine la république se
met-elle de bouc elle a été traînée sur
le banc des gags des guides et des
accusés et pour répondre
disons des crime d'apartheid de
ségrégation de discrimination
d'exclusion de stigmatisation comme si
la république était au bout du compte
coupable des malheurs qui la frappe et
on entend ces derniers temps on entend
depuis quelques puis quelques semaines
un plaidoyer très fort pour ce qu'on
appelle une laïcité ouverte et les
éditions gallimard dans la collection de
débats viennent de faire paraître un
livre à mes yeux très symptomatique dont
des extraits ont été publiés dans le
point constantin langue ils la
possibilité du cosmopolitisme et dans ce
livre il dit précisément que la
république est beaucoup trop lige rigide
et que la pacification des tensions
exige une relaxation des exigences
républicaines assimilatrice et
uniformisante assimilatrice et
uniformisante voyez donc il y a le
problème lié aux nouvelles technologies
la connexion qui remplace de plus en
plus l'attention est ce qui rend la
transmission extraordinairement malaisé
le problème lié à un nouveau public
scolaire que la république hésitent à
intégrer c'est à dire à faire entrer
dans un monde dans une civilisation
particulière pour les raisons que j'ai
dit
il me semble que je dirais pour conclure
que par delà les pauses martial sur le
fait qu'on ne cédera jamais à la terreur
la république ce renonce au moment même
où elle est défié et défier parfois de
façon meurtrières et c'est pour cela
qu'il me semble excusez-moi si ma
conclusion est un peu abstrait abrupte
c'est pour cela qu'il me semble qu'on va
à la catastrophe merci monsieur même si
en effet la conclusion est un petit peu
abrupte mais mes collègues vont poser
des questions d'abord monsieur le
rapporteur est ensuite bien sûr les
questions de mes collègues
merci cela cliniciens moi je suis
vraiment avec l'ensemble de mes
collègues pierre nous sommes fiers et
ravis que vous y ait accepté notre
invitation
parce que nous aimons votre manière de
dire les choses et pas simplement
même si certains disent parfois vous
êtes pessimiste mais je crois que vous
êtes assez réalistes et nous sommes
souvent dans le déni de dire les choses
dans une société actuelle où il faut
il faut il faut effet misé toute
intention de choses moi j'aurai trois
questions la première c'est
l'enseignement des valeurs républicaines
ne serait-il pas au flou qui entoure
leur définition ainsi qu'à la remise en
cause de l'idée nationale
je voulais déplacerait la deuxième
oui c'est la perte d'autorité c'était
pour permettre à me rico les voir
intervenir juste après la perte
d'autorité des enseignants elle défaut
discipline peut-elle expliquer la perte
de repères républicain dans l'impression
qu'il ya un déclin l'autorité du maître
qui est pour certains du fait de
l'institution scolaire ou pour d'autres
d'un mouvement plus général de recul de
l'autorité et la troisième question
n'attendons pas trop de l'école
peut-être pu faire ou se substituer à la
famille dans l'éducation
je vais essayer de répondre du mieux que
je peux à chacune de vos questions alors
je m'arrête d'abord à ce terme très
souvent entendu les valeurs
républicaines
alors si j'ai fait référence à renan
c'est précisément pour l'accent que
celui ci met sur l'héritage un héritage
de gloire et de regret dit-il mais
premièrement cet héritage
l'histoire cet héritage ne commence pas
avec la république
j'ai toujours été fasciné par cette
phrase de peggy la république une et
indivisible
notre royaume de france et je veux dire
la littérature française
apparu miraculeusement en 1789 bout en
1848 ou avec l'instauration définitive
de la république après la guerre de 70
et l'enseignement j'ai bénéficié moi
même d'une éducation nationale
délibérément nationale et je me souviens
que nous étudiions chaque année du coup
nous venions même si les classes étaient
moins bigarré qu'aujourd'hui une pièce
de racine une pièce de corneille une
pièce de molière dont p donc voilà le
flou qui entoure la définition je vois
aussi une sorte de réduction à la
république de ce qu'il s'agit
d'enseigner et puis le mot de valeur je
le trouve un tout petit peu dangereux et
là en effet parce que les valeurs son
jeu d'abord enseigné les valeurs c'est
se condamner as à faire des harengs ou
des sermons je ne suis pas sûr que un
enseignement efficace en passe par le
sermon en outre ces valeurs sont
justiciables d'interprétation
extraordinairement différente car si
aujourd'hui certains remettent en cause
le principe républicain par excellence
qu'est la laïcité ce n'est pas au nom de
la religion
on ne prête plus pour un retour à
l'hétéronomie
les partisans et les adversaires d'une
de la laïcité telle qu'elle fonctionne
aujourd'hui se réclament eux mêmes de la
laïcité ouverte et s'appuie sur la
déclaration des droits de l'homme la
liberté de conscience la liberté
religieuse leur paraît être au fondement
de la modernité la inc
donc ils sont eux mêmes partie prenante
du grand mouvement de sécularisation de
nos sociétés et on invoquera de plus en
plus la liberté de conscience
une certaine idée de laïcité pour
remettre en cause l'interdiction du
voile islamique des signes religieux
ostensibles du voile islamique à l'école
c'est évidemment cet argument qui a été
brandie quand on a commencé à réfléchir
au problème du voile à l'université et à
toutes ses conséquences et c'est aussi
l'argument qu'on invoque pour contester
l'interdiction du voile intégral et de
la burqa et moi je vois même cette
situation soulève
or pourquoi la france tient tel
obstinément bien tel jusqu'à présent à
maintenir ses incessantes érection ce
n'est pas simplement au nom de ces
valeurs
c'est au nom de sa civilisation au nom
de ses moeurs et je vois se profiler si
vous les jeux je vois oui ce scénario se
mettre en place nos moeurs sacrifier à
notre idée du droit et donc nos moeurs
se sont pas simplement des coutumes ce
ne sont pas simplement un folk ce n'est
pas simplement un folklore il y a dans
nos moeurs des valeurs auxquelles nous
sommes attachés mais précisément il ya
quelque chose d'une
ces valeurs et s'exprime dans notre
civilisation et dans nos moeurs et je
crois précisément que il faut que la
france que l'école soit un des lieux
d'apprentissage par delà les valeurs
républicaines de la civilisation
française
évidemment la difficulté comme vous le
soulignez dans votre question tient
aussi à la remise en cause de l'idée
nationale 1
la nation ayant succombé à plusieurs
reprises au nationalisme l'âge étant
venue de la construction européenne il
est de plus en plus difficile de parler
d' assumer même l'existence d'une
civilisation française c'est pourtant me
semble-t-il ce qui doit être réaffirmé
la perte la deuxième la paire de
l'autorité des enseignants et les
défauts de discipline peuvent elles
expliquer la perte des repères
républicain oui si vous voulez là il
faut peut-être en revenir à tocqueville
qui a montré que la démocratie moderne
n'était pas simplement un régime le
régime du gouvernement par le peuple et
pour le peuple la démocratie at il
analysé est un processus un mouvement
historique fascinant et 10 est il
inquiétant
et quand il disait inquiétant ce n'est
pas parce qu'il avait la nostalgie dans
ces régimes
il disait que l'idée démocratique de
liberté était plus juste que l'idée
aristocratique de liberté mais ce
processus était inquiétant c'était quoi
ce processus est un processus
d'égalisation des conditions il disait
il faut pouvoir modérée la démocratie
sinon c'est la civilisation elle-même
qui est mise en péril
si en effet tout devient démocratique
dans la démocratie
eh bien il n'y a plus de verticalité et
l'école est en péril la perte de
l'autorité de recul de l'autorité dans
nos société vient en quelque sorte de
l'hubris égalitaire dans laquelle nos
sociétés auxquelles notre société est
prise et on le voit jusque dans le
discours des politiques certes
l'inégalité économique demeure on peut
même dire que qu'elle se creuse
enfin disons ces sujets à débat mais en
tout cas elle demeure il n'en reste pas
moins que vous entendez toujours parler
de la persistance des inégalités de la
nécessité d'en finir avec les les
inégalités sans que jamais ou sans que
alors que très rarement et affirmer
l'autorité c'est à dire une égalité
positif une inégalité positive une
inégalité nécessaire donc avec l'égalité
tous
tout est mis sur le même plan et il n'y
a plus de hiérarchie entre les pratiques
culturelles et la dissymétrie qui est au
fondement même des institutions et
notamment de l'institution scolaire tend
à disparaître
il n'ya plus d'estrade aujourd'hui dans
les salles de classe et c'est c'est très
symbolique
quand j'ai commencé à enseigner même on
passait dix ou quinze minutes à mettre
les tables en rond bon ça c'est terminé
je dois y est enseigné dans un lycée
technologique où je n'avais aucun
problème
discipline c'est pour ça que cette ces
innovations pédagogiques pouvait se
faire sans trop de casse
on n'en est plus là aujourd'hui mais il
me semble en effet que ce recul de
l'autorité correspond aux vins et une
est un des symptômes de ce mouvement
démocratique d'égalisation auquel il
faut mettre une limite
mais on sait d'autant moins le faire que
précisément tout le discours politique
est organisée autour de la dénonciation
des inégalités nantes en attente at on
n'attend pas trop parler je vais je vais
donner la parole donc à quelques
questions mes collègues et ainsi il ya
des choses sur mon kiki vont se
regrouper
voilà donc monsieur longuet merci madame
la présidente je voudrais vraiment
présenter mes excuses et prier un film
quel drôle de les accepter parce que je
dois défendre un texte à 9h30 texte
fiscal je reviendrai après d'ailleurs ça
peut être très court
moi je voulais de deux choses la
première le remercier de ce qu'il est de
ce qu'il dit de ce qu'il fait sans
courage c'est un vrai bonheur de vous
lire et de vous écouter temps en temps
il faut dire les choses comme en versant
j'avais envie de le dire je vous le dis
à cet instant là la seconde c'est que je
suis en plein accord avec vos deux
points de faiblesse de l'enseignement la
connexion contre la tension
c'est d'ailleurs un problème général de
la société mais qui est plus grave chez
les enfants parce que les enfants sont
plus fragiles que les adultes qui malgré
tout ont réussi à trouver un équilibre
personnel et la seconde en effet la
diversité des héritages pour revenir à
la thèse de renan nous pose un vrai
problème
il n'est pas insurmontable mais il
serait fou de le nier mais c'est pas le
sens de ma question ma question
peut-être manque-t-il quelque chose dans
votre analyse pessimiste je partage
assez largement pas une raison pour l'un
fermé
il faut quand même avoir un diagnostic
c'est ce que j'appellerais le
consumérisme des parents vis-à-vis de
l'école c'est à dire que l'école a été à
son origine
une garantie de succès social de
promotion sociale de promotion
économique et social d'ailleurs les deux
à la fois de statut et de revenus et
aujourd'hui nous avons un doute profond
des parents sur cette fonction de
promotion de statut et de revenus au
moment même où toute la société incline
chacun à être un consommateur exigeant
pour son prestataire et jamais pour lui
est l'une des difficultés que j'ai
rencontrées comme président de région
dense avec les enseignants concernant la
réussite scolaire c'est un chausson le
comportement les comportements des
parents qui ont une attente assez
primitive que je qualifierais d'attentes
de garagiste
on va au lycée comme on va chez le
garagiste qui vous rend une voiture
réparée
le problème c'est que c'est pas tout à
fait la même chose pour l'enseignement
et j'aurais voulu que sur ce thème
l'école certitude de promotion est
aujourd'hui une attente qui est plus
ambigu dans ses résultats et qui donc
affaibli la fonction de fall le
magistère le prestige de l'école à
l'exception naturellement des grandes
écoles des classes préparatoires de tout
ce qui d'une certaine façon perm
garantit la réussite
mais cette garantie de réussite elle est
parfaitement minoritaires et les gros
bataillons eux sont confrontés à une
école dont ils ne ressentent pas
l'utilité complètement l'utilisent de
l'utilité sociale
longuet autre question non c'est bon
restaurant comme ça monsieur longueur à
sa réponse répondre
une question à la fois je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec vous les élèves sont
de moins en moins des élèves et ils ont
une espèce d'où une entité aujourd'hui
c'est comme s'ils étaient les produits
de l'école et quand le produit
défectueux
on se plaint et c'est comme s'il était
en même temps les clients et produits et
clients et c'est une dérive extrêmement
grave
mais là où peut-être je ne vois pas tout
à fait les choses comme vous ou
peut-être nono de réflexion se
complètent
je ne suis pas sûr que l'école autrefois
aux frais se présentait comme garantie
de promotion sociale ou du moins elle
avait aux yeux des parents eux mêmes
une autre fonction qui faisait tout son
prestige
j'ai eu à l'école polytechnique un très
brillante élève major je crois
maintenant derrière qui d'état à l'ump
il s'appelait vincent le bissap elle
toujours vincent le biais et je
discutais avec lui ai d'abord il a eu
lui il m'a dit qui venait d'une famille
d'agriculteurs du cotentin des petits
agriculteurs et disais je lui demandais
mais alors qu'est ce que vos parents
attendait de vous esquisse aspirait à
travers votre réussite scolaire une
promotion sociale et qui faisait
pression pour que par vos diplômes vous
sortiez du 2 2 voilà de leur propre
horizons il me dit non la seule chose
qui me demandait c'était de ramener de
bons bulletins et je me souviens que mes
parents avaient exactement la même
attente c'est à dire que l'école c'est
le lieu notamment l'enseignement
secondaire
en france c'est le lieu de transmission
du savoir l'acquisition d'une culture
générale et l'école était valorisé pour
cela par les parents laurent lafforgue
mathématicien médaille fields qui s'est
engagé il ya plusieurs années dans un
dans une véritable croisade pour les
humanités a écrit un article absolument
magnifique pour la revue conférence
intitulée la confusion des ordres il en
revient
il part de la fameuse distinction d
ordre pascalienne l'ordre de la chaire
l'ordre de l'esprit l'ordre de la
charité et il constate que si vous
voulez l'idée même de grandeur de
l'esprit semble disparaître par
sollicitude au nom de l'égalité donc de
la charité on voudrait la réussite pour
tous c'est de la raison pour laquelle
d'ailleurs j'ai démissionné de la
commission thélot parce que je ne
comprenais rien à ce slogan je le
trouvais je trouvais il y avait quelque
chose c'est soviétique
c'est pour tous et donc j'ai démissionné
on veut la réussite pour tous mais
d'autre part on ne voit pas on ne sait
plus penser l'autonomie des grandeurs de
l'esprit d'où d'ailleurs le le stress de
discrédit dont les enseignants sont
l'objet puisque il ne gagne que 15 100
euros par mois et on ne peut pas faire
partie de l'élite
quand on gagne 15 100 euros par mois or
les professeurs de lycée un autant de la
république des professeurs n'étaient pas
riches mais il faisait partie d'une
élite parce que précisément d'autres
critères intervenait donc ce qui me
paraît extraordinairement dangereux
c'est le fait que la finalité première
de l'école est notamment de
l'enseignement secondaire cultiver les
élèves est bien c'est que cette finalité
est disparu de notre horizon mental d'où
cette attente extrêmement brutal il faut
ne faire réussir
et si vous ne me fais pas réussir et
bien c'est votre faute
et évidemment
les pauvres professeurs sont traités
comme des prestataires de service et
autre fois alors je m'excuse j'ai l'air
d'un membre réactionnaire mains d'un
nostalgique incorrigible mais d'abord on
avait peur quand on allait à l'école on
est toujours un peu peur les élèves
avaient un peu peur
pas forcément peur des punitions mais et
les parents avait le ventre noué quand
il allait voir les professeurs il
oui se demandaient ce qu'ils allaient
dire or là si le professeur sanctionne
l'élève
il arrive très souvent que les parents
s'en prennent à lui pourquoi avez vous
fait ça c'est mon enfant ne le méritait
pas c'est à vous de mieux vous occuper
de lui
c'est à vous de le faire réussir ce mot
de réussite
si vous voulez tendent à éclipser celui
là me le le le mot de culture et la
disparition de ce mot de culture est
effectivement très inquiétante
merci beaucoup monsieur vous regarderez
la suite en vidéo
monsieur manier votre question nous
tombent en pluie même la présidente
monsieur académiciens merci de vos
éclairages
j'arrive pas bien à comprendre pourquoi
il faut prêter serment pour dire ce que
vous venez de dire franchement je le
dirai plusieurs reprises je vois pas
pourquoi on fait une commission d'
enquête sur cette affaire
et pourquoi je ne comprends pas monsieur
académiciens pourquoi on vous fait
prêter serment pour dire ce que vous
venez de dire franchement oui mais
justement ces formes là on avait déjà eu
l'occasion de dire et je le répète
aujourd'hui une commission d'information
très bien pu entendre ce que vous avez à
dire ce que nous avons à dire en tout
cas merci de votre intervention
la fin de votre propos m'amène à
reparler un peu de ce que j'évoque
souvent parce que je suis moi même
enseignant d'origine de formation et je
n'étais je crois que parmi ceux qui sont
là j'étais un des derniers dans une
classe si j étais encore dans l'année
scolaire 2010 2011 avant de devenir
sénateur
et je crois qu'on a par rapport à
l'école mais on l'a aussi pour beaucoup
de choses dans cette société un peu le
mythe du passé béni comme six autres
fois avant tout était mieux
l'école est à même aujourd'hui qui
regrette du service militaire à m'a
franchement je vous dis j'ai fait le
service militaire je regrette pas par
contre qu'il y ait un lieu de rencontre
des jeunes de ce pays quelque part
organisé d'une certaine manière qui ne
soit pas forcément militaire ça ne
paraît pas une mauvaise chose
je pourrais prendre d'autres exemples
l'école elle est dans la société elle
est forcément immergée d'un société la
société change pas l'école qui changent
écoles
elle doit changer en même temps que la
société elle va changer seul c'est pas
un îlot même si parfois ça devrait
l'être par rapport à cette nombre de
problèmes qui peuvent se poser dans la
société
les enseignants aujourd'hui son parti
d'un monde qui n'est pas un monde à part
par contre ce qu'on peut contester c'est
la façon dont ils sont formés
aujourd'hui donc ils l'ont été dans les
quelques dizaines les dix dernières
années moi j'ai eu la chance d'être un
enseignant formé à l'école normale
d'instituteurs même si ce n'est pas le
nec plus ultra de la formation ça
l'était pas mal pour les enseignants je
crois aujourd'hui que si on peut
regretter et c'est peut-être un peu un
des maux dont souffre notre école c'est
d'avoir des enseignantes qui sont un peu
démunis parce que mal formés justement
la loi de fondation de l'école fait un
une part belle à la formation des
enseignants dans des établissements qui
ne s'appelle plus les iufm qui
s'appelait plus normal mais qui
s'appelle les écoles supérieures de
professeurs à l'éducation et dans lequel
on essaie de redéfinir la formation des
enseignants et de redéfinir ce qu'est le
socle commun des enfants de 7 de ce pays
de connaissance
parce que c'est d'abord la connaissance
à l'école de compétences qu'il faut
aussi connaissance des bouchons des
compétences pour la réussite
professionnelle notamment et deux
valeurs que sont les valeurs culturelles
que vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure donc
je crois que va poser vos interventions
vos explications nous font comprendre
effectivement aujourd'hui l'école elle
est soumise sa tombe de difficultés qui
viennent de l'extérieur
cette commission denquête aujourd'hui
qui est mise en place
et nous permettra certainement de
débattre comme nous l'avons fait
longuement lors de l'élaboration de la
loi de 2013 sur la refondation de
l'école on peut débattre effectivement
longtemps sur l'école mais je ne pense
pas qu'elle soit un élément différent de
tous les autres éléments de la société
il faut qu'elle évolue et je pense pas
qu'il soit nécessaire non plus de faire
le procès des parents d'élèves
vous savez moi j'ai connu les pandev qui
viennent toujours aujourd'hui en 2015 un
peu en tremblant à l'école parce que
pour eux c'est pas toujours ça me de
venir voir le maître le maîtresse de
l'école je connais encore
malheureusement des enfants qui vont à
l'école avec un peu la peur au ventre
comme vous le disiez tout à l'heure pour
un certain nombre de raisons parce
qu'ils ont peur d'échouer parce que ils
sont inquiets parce qu'ils sont
différents parce que etc
il ya encore la peur la crainte du
maître mais je crois qu'on a tendance à
généraliser des faits particuliers
effectivement il ya des gens qui n'ont
peur de rien parce qu'ils ont les moyens
parce que ils viennent à l'école comme
ils viennent dans des lieux de
consommation ça a été dit c'est vrai
mais ça n'est pas tu crois la généralité
voilà ce que je voulais dire merci chers
collègues je vais donc donner la parole
à monsieur l'académicien jeu juste dire
donc pour qu'il n'ait pas l'impression
que ce soit lui qui soit qui est mis en
cause et c'est vraiment donc notre
différence entre commission denquête
émissions d'information le choix qui a
été fait n'a pas été celui de tout le
monde mais vous n'y êtes pour rien donc
je vous laisse répondre je veux les 10
j'aime les formes j'aime les rites donc
je me suis soumis à cette obligation
avec sans aucun problème écoutez je suis
très étonné
de ce que vous avez dit sur la part
entre ritournelle du c'était mieux avant
je constate que plus le présent se
révèle invivable et plus on tend à
ridiculiser voir à criminaliser la
nostalgie j'ai vu il y a deux ans un
professeur d'un lycée professionnel qui
avait été tabassé par un élève et qui a
dit à la télévision
c'est visiblement pas c'est pas un
professeur à l'ancienne il se présentait
comme les professeurs sont habiles
aujourd'hui souvent en jeans et en tee
shirt
c'est justement de principe égalitaire
qui touche qui affecte les professeurs
eux-mêmes
on ne ne portent certainement plus la
cravate aujourd'hui quand on va quand on
va enseigner au lycée bien et il disait
il a eu cette phrase il faut bien le
savoir l'enseignement aujourd'hui c'est
un sport de combat en 1974-75 je sais
plus j'ai été nommé juste après mon
agrégation professeur dans un lycée
technique de beauvais à l'orée de
beauvais j'étais très content d'obtenir
ce poste parce que je pouvais rentrer à
paris je n'avais pas à m'installer
plus loin un honneur pour trois ou
quatre jours et c'est l obsession des
jeunes engagés
je ne me suis jamais posé la question de
la discipline je n'ai jamais pensé que
ça allait être dangereux pour moi je
n'avais pas cette peur il m'arrivait de
rater mes cours et les élèves me le
faisait sentir
mais c'était c'était tout alors et
j'entends dire aussi que maintenant
alors nous avions par exemple des heures
de ferveur pédagogiques dont j'ai parlé
l'état blanc etc
mais maintenant on vous explique que on
a besoin de professionnaliser
et les professeurs la transmission du
savoir ne suffit pas à elle seule à
faire un bon professeur c'est quand même
étonnant c'est une rupture avec avec
avec avec plusieurs siècles d'éducation
avec l'éducation elle même ce qu'on
demandait un professeur c'est de çà va
transmettre ça pourquoi vous dites on
est efficace parce que maintenant il
s'agit de tenir sa place
le grand problème c'est qu'il faut des
professeurs aguerris pour qu'il sache
tenir leur classe on ne m'a même dans
made
moi jamais dit ou ne jamais donner des
recettes pour tenir ma classe c'est pas
vrai ce n'est pas vrai jamais et c'était
les années 70 il s'est quand même
produit une rupture extrêmement violente
c'est le cas de le dire et et d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs sa chambre quand même
aujourd'hui quand un élève un brillant
élève passe l'agrégation
c'est avec l'idée qu'il faudra qu'ils se
débrouillent pour ne pas enseigner ou
pour trouver immédiatement un poste dans
le supérieur
nous nous voulions enseigner près de
paris voilà c'était avoir un bon
classement pour pouvoir enseigner
préparé mais ne pas enseigner non
c'était pas ce n'était pas notre
objectif
j'étais plutôt content de devenir
professeur et donc il se passe quelque
chose
la crise des vocations vient de la
nouvelle situation faite au professeur
dans l'enseignement d'aujourd'hui et
cette situation alors là je vais
définitivement mettre les pieds dans le
plat à un lien évidemment avec le
nouveau public scolaire donc avec
l'immigration et ce lien il est très
difficile avait j'ajoute même que si la
nostalgie est criminalisé aujourd'hui on
le voit très bien c'est parce que on a
l'air de regretter l'époque d'une
certaine homogénéité culturelle et
ethnique et ce faisant on est suspect de
racisme
souvenez-vous des attaques qui ont été
lancée contre un certain nombre de films
comme les enfants du marais comme amélie
poulain ou comme les dons s'appelait pas
les chanteurs qu'un peu importe j'ai
oublié mais les choristes pardon qui
n'étaient pas de grands films je sais
mais tout d'un coup on dise à regarder
pourquoi il aime ça pourquoi ça leur
plaît parce que ce n'est pas la
diversité parce que ce n'est pas la
france multi ethnique
on aurait plus de 2,2 de latitude pour
critiquer le présent si le présent
n'était pas celui de la diversité car
critiqué le président de la diversité
c'est évidemment 10 on se se montrer
coupable de quelque chose de pas bien et
il me semble que les les
les les professeurs aujourd'hui sont
dans une situation qu'ils n'ont jamais
connu jamais mais qui n'a pas de
précédent
alors je ne veux absolument pas
idéaliser l'époque où j'ai été élève ou
l'époque où j'étais enseignant j'ai
connu de longues périodes d'ennui j'ai
connu des professeurs ils ont beaucoup
trop autoritaire pour le coup d'autres
qui n'étaient pas à la hauteur de leurs
fonctions tout cela est vrai il n'en
reste pas moins que les problèmes que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui n'existe
pas et et la difficulté de le dire tient
précisément à ce que cela met sur le
tapis une question on a beaucoup de mal
à regarder en face qui est la question
de l'immigration de peuplement devait
juste rebondir parce que bon bien sûr
dans tout ce que vous avez dit il ya la
transmission de savoirs mais je pense
que il y a aussi tout ce qu'il ya
derrière la pédagogie et c'est vrai
qu'un professeur agrégé n'a peut-être
pas tout à fait la même
les mêmes classes aujourd'hui dans des
collèges et sait très bien que vous ayez
eu envie d'enseigner je suis assez
d'accord c'est dommage que quelqu'un qui
deviennent professeurs même agrégé n'ai
pas envie d'enseigner surtout pas ça
c'est vraiment très dommage mais c'est
vrai que nous sommes à plusieurs niveaux
donc l'école primaire le collège et le
lycée mais je vais laisser donc monsieur
ça va me poser sa question excusez moi
chers collègues non merci madame la
présidente monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur l'académicienne merci pour pour
les propos que vous tenez qui c'est vrai
dresse un peu un tableau assez
pessimiste de la situation mais petit
personnage je crois qu en effet ce
tableau et est très proche de la réalité
que nous vivons au quotidien
à ma question va avoir un lien avec les
événements qui se sont déroulés mois de
janvier dernier
nous avons entendu déploré la faiblesse
de la réponse gouvernementale dans le
domaine de l'éducation
parce que se contente cette réponse se
contenter de réaffirmer des valeurs et
vous l'avez souligné tout à l'heure près
ce que vous appelez vous de vos voeux un
retour de la rigueur à l'école alors
pourriez-vous peut-être développé cette
idée évoquée la forme que vous pourrez
prendre selon vous ce retour de leur
rigueur aussi bien dans les classes que
dans les programmes scolaires qui vous
en êtes d'accord ils poseront tous les
deux leurs questions ainsi vous pourrez
répondre
voilà ce n'est pas de votre faute c'est
que le terrain est très est compté merci
l'école et les victimes de ce qu'elle
s'est donnée comme mission et c'est une
mission qu absolument incontestable
c'est à dire la démocratisation dans les
années 60 tout le monde n'allait pas au
lycée j'ai encore connu
l'examen d'entrée en sixième par exemple
donc ceux qui étaient au lycée et en
particulier quand ils étaient issus de
familles modestes
conscients qu'ils avaient eu la chance
d'aller là où leurs parents n'avaient
pas pu aller et les parents étaient tout
à fait décidée à l'est
leur faire sentir la nécessité de la
discipline parce qu'ils avaient de la
chance et qu'ils n'avaient pas le droit
de la gâcher je crois que maintenant
dans la mesure où tout le monde quand il
entre à l'école à vocation d'aller
jusqu'au baccalauréat et au delà
ce sentiment a plus ou moins disparu il
ya une exigence des parents que vous
puissiez suivre
et s'il est que les élèves puissent
suivre
année après année et si les professeurs
y met obstacles parce qu'ils estiment
que le niveau des pattes
à ce moment là effectivement certains
parents vont croire devoir s'en prendre
non pas à leurs chers élèves mais aux
professeurs c'est un peu ça peut exister
mais la société élections'' différente
parce qu'on a d'abord donné comme
objectif que tout le monde puisse aller
le plus loin possible
ça a des conséquences la deuxième c'est
que quand nous avions un diplôme contrat
et est professeur agrégé ou certifiés on
était assuré de d'avoir une place dans
la société parce que le diplôme étaient
rares même s'il n'est pas en que
dévaloriser il n'empêche quand même que
les diplômés - rare que la paix il n'a
pas suivi toujours et que un professeur
de lycée dans un une ville moyenne je
suis élu d'une ville moyenne
c'était peut-être quelque chose il ya 40
ou 50 ans c'est maintenant une fonction
banal parce qu'ils feraient compte des
quantités d'autres gens qui sont sortis
de l'université avec bac + 3 à bac + 5
qui sont les parents de leurs élèves et
tout ceci est normal d'assister de ce
point de vue là c'est un peu
homogénéiser je ne suis pas persuadé que
nous pourrons modifier ce genre de
choses il ya points kim doit être nuancé
un peu aussi vous avez parlé et c'est un
vrai problème des enfants issus de
l'immigration et qui peuvent se sentir
hétérogène dans les classes et posé des
problèmes mais il ya aussi des problèmes
dans des villes moyennes dont les lycées
ne sont pas particulièrement marquée par
une forte présence d'élèves issus de
l'immigration
donc il ya le problème des
hélicéa forte ou des collèges à forte
population d'enfants d'origine étrangère
et dont les parents peut-être ne
maîtrisait pas la langue française etc
il ya aussi des problèmes dans des
villes moyennes où ça ne joue pas tout à
fait non je pense qu'il faut peut-être
un petit peu élargir la problématique et
ne pas la limiter à sous a indiqué le
dernier point qui me paraît très
intéressant c'est que la société elle a
toujours évolué en même temps que
l'école est que l a eu tendance toujours
à établir les familles les plus
favorisés quand une évolution les
inquiétait elle a toujours eu tendance à
mettre en place des systèmes dérivés
pour échapper à l'évolution et faire en
sorte que même dans le service public y
ait de bons lycées et de moins bons
lycées et qu'on publie ça m'a toujours
surpris et un peu choqués dans la presse
la liste des bons établissements des
moins bons établissements ce qui est
parfaitement contraire à l'éthique qui
que l'école veut développer faut savoir
ce que l'on veut où on classe les
établissements où on dit que l'on veut
la réussite pour le plus grand nombre
bon ben je crois que c'est ainsi et il
ya un point qui est très symptomatique
j'ai fait le dessus des rapports c'est
la classe préparatoire aux grandes
écoles qui est quand même le
l'instrument de là
de la diversification sociale on se rend
compte que les classes prépas continue à
avoir des recrutements extrêmement
sélectif et qu'elles ne sont loin d'être
présente
géographiquement sur l'ensemble du
territoire et quand vous regardez la
carte des classes prépas vous apercevez
qu'elle reflète aussi une certaine
sociologie mais ça on en parle peu et
quand on veut faire avancer les choses
ou les modifier
on se heurte à un silence à tours 10
assourdissant
quelle que soit la majorité est
quelquefois le gouvernement je me
permets de faire ces quelques remarques
l'école défend l'indépendance de l'ordre
et spirituelle le l'enseignant l
instituteur disait péguy n'est pas le
représentant d'une majorité n'est pas
reluisant de l'état il n'est pas le
représentant de la société
il est le représentant des poètes et des
artistes
il est le représentant de la culture or
précisément aujourd'hui
cette représentation est remise en cause
et l'une des raisons pour lesquelles on
refuse à l'école les signes religieux
ostensibles c'est que derrière ces
signes il y a l'affirmation que la
culture doit être soumise à des
considérations et des valeurs plus haute
c'est tout le sens du rapport obin un
rapport enterré en 2004 un rappeur qui
parlait justement des problèmes des
signes religieux dans les établissements
dits sensibles car il existe moi je veux
bien que il ne les problèmes ailleurs je
les dis et il faut élargir mais élargir
ça ne doit pas être noyé le poisson non
plus or tout est fait aujourd'hui en
france de toutes les manières et de de
tous les côtés pour noyer le poisson
donc est ce que rapport obin disait
c'est que effectivement il y avait la
question du voile mais derrière la
question du voile est levé la
contestation des cours et c'est vrai
aussi dans l'enseignement supérieur
quand le voile est très présent dans
l'enseignement supérieur eh bien les
professeurs eux-mêmes dans ce qu'ils
disent sont contestés et la culture doit
être défendu l'indépendance de l'ordre
spirituel doit être défendu et donc cela
exige des règles cela exige
une certaine rigueur là encore une
certaine intransigeance
donc je défends l'intransigeance contre
une ouverture qui équivaut pour employer
le terme récemment remise à la mode à de
la soumission
d'autre part pour en venir à la
démocratisation oui la démocratisation a
été une ambition elle était inscrite
déjà à l'horizon la république c'était
ce que ossip mandelstam a appelé dans un
poème la splendide promesse faite au
quatrième et à un promesse justement de
cultiver tout le monde mais on a voulu
et c'est très légitime accélérer les
choses
donc on à massifier enseignement le
résultat le résultat c'est qu'il y a
moins il faut bien le dire il y a moins
d'élèves issus des milieux modestes dans
les classes préparatoires et à l'école
polytechnique qu'avant c'est ça le
raisin il y en a moins il y en a moins
depuis la démocratisation et il suffit
de 10
lisez le premier homme liz est le
premier roman de camus
voyez ce cas était monsieur germain
monsieur germain de toute façon n'aurait
pas sa place dans l'enseignement
d'aujourd'hui il n'aurait pas sa place
les inspecteurs le suspendrait pour sa
sévérité et héééé albert camus ne serait
pas devenu il n'aurait pas pu le devenir
et pourquoi eh bien on le voit je
parlais de l'héritage tout à l'heure
mais sous pensons à l'effet dans
l'institution d'un livre comme celui de
pierre bourdieu les héritiers c'est un
livre qui nous dit voilà il ya des gens
qui sont nés dans la bourgeoisie et
finalement les choses
ils ont acquis une sorte de capitale
culturelle avant l'école et l'école
finalement elle et elle les désignent
sous couleur d'égalité des chances
elle choisit délai déjà héritiers ceux
qui sont dans la connivence de la
culture résultat c'est à l'héritage
qu'on s'en est pris c'est à lui culture
générale donc on supprime dans un
certain nombre de concours et de
concours administratifs aux grands
applaudissements du cran
le comité représentatif des associations
noires de france parce que dit-on la
culture générale avantage et ça c'est
une expression qu'on entend ça fait
partie des éléments de langage ceux qui
ont les codes
il ya ceux qui ont les codes et il ya
ceux qui n'ont pas les codes donc lyn
héritage devient trop programme parce
que précisément on se dit oui mais c'est
trop facile
il ya des gens il ya des gens qui ont
déjà un capital culturel d'autres qui
n'en n'ont pas et ben si précisément on
faisait fi de ce capital
on réalise ray mieux l'égalité le
résultat c'est qu'en effet les enfants
des milieux défavorisés ont de moins en
moins de chances de s'élever quant aux
autres quant aux enfants d'enseignants
aux enfants de milieux défavorisés
on les met dans des écoles ou une
idéologie comme celle là ne sévit pas où
et il est tout à fait légitime
étant donné la situation le désastre
scolaire d'aujourd'hui que les journaux
en effet publie les palmarès des lycées
parce que tous les parents se posent la
question
il faut bien le savoir tous les parents
alors on pour on voit on va on va on va
peut-être durcir la carte scolaire
mais tous les apparences autrefois on
mettait ses enfants et encore une fois
moi j'habitais dans le 10e
arrondissement
on m'a mis dans l'école d'à côté et mes
parents ne réfléchissez pas le la
confiance dans l'école publique régnait
reyniès était simple c'était tout à fait
noir on met dans l'école publique
après et tout va bien mais maintenant ce
n'est plus vrai j'ai mis mon fils - au
lycée lakanal
je me suis installé à bourg-la-reine
pour qu'il soit mis au lycée lakanal et
j'ai même fait jouer mes relations pour
qu'il soit au collège lakanal plutôt
qu'au collège evariste-galois qui était
tout près parce que c'était un collège
difficile mais mon choix du lycée
lakanal a été désastreux déjà désastreux
parce que ce n'était plus un grand effet
c'était devenu un mot valise et j'aurais
dû le mettre au collège sévigné à paris
j'aurais dû faire ça et je ne l'ait pas
fait je ne vais pas fait mais que des
parents aient conscience de la situation
c'est quand même la moindre des choses
il faut bien qu'ils défendent leurs
enfants il faut bien que il
ils veulent assurer à leurs enfants une
éducation digne de ce nom
il veut les kills de mettre à l'abri
d'une idéologie égalitaire qui au bout
du compte
entretien les pires des inégalités
merci beaucoup donc je crois que nous
allons bien sûr arrêter même si nous
resterions beaucoup plus longtemps avec
vous mais nous avons d'autres solutions
merci monsieur l'académicienne merci
bien
voilà pour cette audition sur le thème
de l'éducation et la perte de repères
républicain la commission denquête au
sénat auditionnait alain finkielkraut le
philosophe essayiste et membre de
l'académie française est venu dresser un
constat très pessimistes devant les
sénateurs
pour lui la république semble renoncer
au moment même où elle est défiée
l'école est confronté à de nouvelles
difficultés des élèves de plus en plus
connectés de moins en moins attentifs et
puis un nouveau public scolaire souvent
issus de l'immigration ce qui pose de
nouvelles difficultés à l'école la
commission d' enquête continue ses
auditions des auditions vous pouvez
toujours voir et revoir sur notre site
publicsenat.fr
très bonne journée à vous sur les
chaînes parlementaires